Oil, Gas and Petrochemicals.
The Baku-Tbilisi-Ceyhan pipeline, sometimes known as the BTC pipeline,...
...transports crude oil 1,000 miles...
...from the Azeri-Chirag-Guneshli oil field in the Caspian Sea...
...to the Mediterranean Sea.
The length of the pipeline itself is 1,760 kilometers,...
...so it's one of the longest pipelines in the world.
It passes through Azerbaijan, Georgia and Turkey.
The pipeline has a 42-inch diameter for most of its length,...
...narrowing to a 36-inch diameter when it gets near Ceyhan.
Normal capacity, from 2009 onwards, is expected to be 1,000,000 barrels,...
...in other words, 160,000 cubic metres of oil per day.
It has a capacity of 10 million barrels of oil.
It is hoped that the pipeline will be in use for 50 years.